yes I have finally hit a million
subscribers now I feel important and I
just farted so it smells like rotten
sesame seeds in here hey what's going on
YouTube as pretty mentioned for mention
before yes I hit a million throw
Scrabble but now that I've been on
YouTube now for almost three to four
years one of the most questions asked
one of the most questions asked
[ __ ] you speak English what a
deep those questions I get asked is how
do I play fine miss on the little toe
you know for me this is a very weird
question to ask me that I've never
really sat down and tried to figure this
[ __ ] out you know when I first started
doing YouTube I really didn't know what
this platform was do you know what I
actually use this ship for and I never
openly admitted this Korean dramas over
you pour over oh oh
touch my Kochi but in all honesty even
before that I was using it see if like a
fine point it's really not my fault
because at that time I just found out
that you were started streaming that
disgusting [ __ ] you know my downloaded a
look don't judge me I was 280 pounds I
had acne and I just got done I had to do
something to make me feel better [ __ ]
look there is an old Korean saying
sometimes you gotta beat your dick like
an Asian kid with bad grades listen at
least I'm honest ladies if you ever meet
a man that says he has never watched
porn in his life what you need to do is
scratch out his [ __ ] eyeballs your
damn [ __ ] liar yeah you ain't never
watched porn you must be one of those
dudes and look at titties and say I
respect the mind get the [ __ ] out of
here you want to see my search history
in college you there's a lot of respect
to me by the time I was 21 Google had
bad me for life that Modi admitted porn
my god but I digress let's get back to
the topic how do you become famous on
YouTube look if you haven't really
noticed by now YouTube hasn't been a
space for artistry and original content
in quite a few years
look I've been doing vlogs and sketches
since day one and I've been doing what I
wanted to do prusik with everybody else
now numbers nebular ship wise do i think
that was a smart choice no which is what
surprised I even hit a million
subscribers look if you're looking for a
quick game on you
it's really not that difficult just do
whatever the [ __ ] everybody else is
doing just have to follow trends because
once again YouTube is not a space for
artistry oh [ __ ] no I didn't yes I
[ __ ] said it has not been like that
for a while and I've seen it with my own
eyes it has begun
here's a quick formula do pranks cute
things with Japanese music behind it
ridiculous and raunchy [ __ ] marginalize
and exploit your ethnicity and culture
or state the [ __ ] obvious you want to
be YouTube famous I could think of some
[ __ ] right now go [ __ ] a donkey with a
celery stick they marry and call this
[ __ ] a Bloody Mary disgusting
famous you'll be known as donkey [ __ ]
for the rest of your life but at least
everybody knows you famous
look the sole purpose of my channel was
the fact that I wanted to make content
that make me laugh and in turn I was
hoping it would do the same for you a
lot of you may or may not know this but
I started off as an aspiring stand-up
comedian no not me saying I make jokes
to my friends in a [ __ ] living room
or an ik camera where I just make jokes
at it I was an inspiring static
convenient which means every night and
every weekend I wrote jokes I performed
that [ __ ] at clubs just to see if
something would pop off famous now when
life got really tough for me when I was
a full-time student and I was working
two jobs and I was trying to do music I
had to figure out a way to put up my
content out there without taking so much
time out of my life this is just me
writing and telling stories and opinions
about how I think and how I feel about
certain situations in my life
if it makes a million views yes that's
dope but all that matters is that the
video is somebody left that's what I do
comedy the first place for now unless
then you're saying that I wouldn't like
all the views that they got but you know
my god like that you have a tiger stuff
you don't need [ __ ] because it make you
feel better about your own situation
[ __ ] [ __ ] oxygen I'll need that [ __ ]
but in all honesty I'm happy that I can
create content that connects to the
viewership that I have with youth a year
and because of all your guys's continued
support you know I actually hit a
million subscribers which adds a small
feat but you know it's something but of
course I can always use a little more
scrilla you know Fame so share my [ __ ]
at a certain point I was so broke I
thought about sucking dick for a living
getting halfway maybe this show went a
little too far and famous hey what is
going on YouTube now yes I did hit a
million subscribers thanks to your guys
support and I just want to say thank you
but you know I used to do this thing
back in the day with my YouTube where I
used to ask what you guys wanted me to
talk about and I am serious about that
stuff so what you can do is go on my
Facebook fan page and just ask away ask
about topics that you want me to talk
about or send me articles or videos and
I'll start doing that again because I
want to get you guys a little bit more
involved but anyways happy Wednesdays
and I'll see you guys Sunday Sunday I
will post a video this week I didn't
felt kind of busy but you know I'm
coming back to it with the young famous